and I want to start with the case for
capitalism and I want to lay out some of
the good stuff so for those of you who
want to burn down the world I'll get
there but um not right now
so one of the gifts of the Enlightenment
was to free people from obedience to the
church and to the state and allow them
to use their reason to discover useful
knowledge that made their lives better
to innovate and to track and barter
freely to reap the benefits of new ideas
as many historians have documented there
were subsequently an astonishing
explosion of well-being
useful knowledge in the form of
discoveries and applied science in
engineering and in public health brought
greater Prosperity as well as more years
of life in which to enjoy it
improvements in sanitation reduced
infant mortality and helped control
infectious disease the development of
The Germ theory of disease brought an
understanding of the common causes of
disease and understanding that over time
could be exported to the whole world
the Industrial Revolution spread from
Britain and Northeast Europe bringing
Rising Prosperity with it much if not
most of this progress came by leveling
up by extending good things from the few
to the many in other words by reducing
inequalities
capitalism was not responsible for all
of this but by allowing people to
benefit and get rich from new ways of
doing things it played an important part
in encouraging it
now I could spend the rest of this
lecture and in fact the rest of today
documenting what happened but I can
summarize in just a few slides so let me
show you the first slide
so this shows life expectancy at Birth
um in England and Wales from 1850 to the
beginning of the current century
it Rose from 40
in the middle of the 19th century 40
years to its current value of around 80.
in the early days when life expectancy
was 40 very few people actually died at
age 40. people died as children or if
they escaped that fate
they had a good chance of surviving into
an old age
figure two shows the this is figure two
sorry it shows the ages at which people
died in Sweden and the Netherlands in
1751 1920 and 2019. the horizontal axis
shows age and the vertical access the
number of deaths per thousand at each
age
the left-hand axis uses a proportional
scale which exaggerates changes at low
mortality rates and flattens them out at
the high mortality rates what I want you
to take away from this picture is its
u-shape this is the u-shape and that the
U has deepened over time it's moved
downwards
the danger points to life are at the
beginning of Life for babies
and at the end of life for the elderly
if you survive the first year of life
you don't have much chance of dying
until middle age or Beyond after the
second world war the improvements in
health first and then later in material
Prosperity began to spread to the poorer
parts of the world in east and south
Asia in Africa and Latin America
the health Innovations based on the germ
theory of disease clean water and
vaccinations were figured out in the
Richer countries and then passed on as
gifts from the north to the South they
were not at least at first a consequence
of the spread of Freedom or free markets
to poorer regions
the Gap in life expectancy between rich
and poor countries are between northern
Europe and sub-Saharan Africa closed
rapidly in the last 50 years an
international inequality in life
expectancy has declined rapidly
so now we get to the story of capitalism
in the magic markets Better Health in
poor countries happen mostly by copying
lessons from the north which is why life
expectancy could increase in countries
with little or no income growth but it
is inconceivable that the dramatic gains
in income could have taken place without
the help of markets particularly Global
markets the reduction in poverty despite
the growth of world pop world population
over the same period is an almost
incredible achievement unlike anything
else that has ever happened in human
history
we're used to hearing about it so
perhaps you're not as Amazed by this
graph as you ought to be
certainly viewed from the 1970 when
there was widespread pessimism by the
expanding population and the poverty
that it would quotes inevitably bring
with it people would simply have refused
to believe that this could happen yet it
did
and it is impossible to imagine it
having happened without markets and
without globalization
when my libertarian friends want to sing
the Praises of Classical liberalism this
together with the improvements in health
are the numbers that they rightly
trumpet this is the case for global
capitalism and it's a strong case indeed